hi guys scifi recapped here before we
start warning spoilers ahead today i'm
going to explain a 2018 american science
fiction and thriller movie called higher
power this movie delivers a very deep
meaning about the relationship between
father and daughters
make sure to watch it till the end to
find out the movie begins with a quote
telling that he will create his own god
to save the world a mass scientist
called the controller is doing research
about a power that can transform a man
into a superhuman when a mysterious guy
suddenly contacts him through encrypted
messages telling him that he knows about
the professor's work and him being
kicked out by the organization the guy
then offers a plan to bring the research
into reality that will be used to save
the world from the upcoming apocalypse
because the invention needs a subject
the controller immediately begins a
research for dna analysis until he finds
a man joseph steadman the scene jumps to
an interview with the astrophysicist
michael swofford who claims that
gamma-ray bursts will be the last thing
that mankind will see before the
apocalypse he adds that a high-mass star
is going to collapse which will emit two
narrow gamma-ray beams and earth is
lying directly in the path of the beam
zone meaning that the earth will be
destroyed
on the other side joseph or joe is a
recovering alcoholic and currently works
as a security guard at redlock he
replaced the old recording showing his
quality time with his daughter on a
seashore he told his daughter zoe three
magic words 143 which stands for i love
you turns out that the controller has
been observing and filming everything
joe does the system then reveals that
joe is undergoing psychiatric treatment
for depression and suicidal tendencies
so he wants to kill himself and he also
has an anger problem zoe unfortunately
only makes things worse for his father
she thinks joe was responsible for the
death of her mother and hates him for
that surprisingly she's having a
relationship with michael on the other
hand reya zoe's younger sister is a drug
addict and is constantly being utilized
by a pimp nico the controller's men keep
following and tracking joey's daughter's
movements while at the library michael
mentions finding somebody that increases
the possibility of a more optimistic
future for mankind a recording shows
that before joey's wife's death he used
to have a harmonious family ray was
still a very happy teenager and zoey
still loved her dad he then tries to
reconnect with zoe but it seems like his
daughter doesn't want to meet him again
he even ends up punching michael which
makes zoe furious that night while
driving joey attempts to call reya
trying to fix things with her but she
doesn't pick up the phone he then pulls
over and starts drinking again while
flashbacking his memories with his wife
he promised her to keep their family
together but he failed a few moments
later a man who has been hiding in the
back seat kidnaps him and brings him to
the controller he implants a chip into
joey's eyes which allows him to see what
he sees shows him what the controller
wants to see and talks to him when joe
awakens the controller forces him to
grab a pistol and kills a woman at first
he resists to do so but he threatens him
that his man will kill his daughter joe
reluctantly follows his order turns out
that the gun is empty and the woman is
the controller's agent who is testing
his obedience
at this point a huge star has just
exploded and the beam is currently
heading towards earth joe awakens and is
directed by the controller to break into
his boss's house his boss charles is the
president of redlock while monitored joe
manages to get in and orders charles to
bring him the safe where a laptop is
being kept he then scans his finger on
the fingertip scanner and it reveals
that joe's dna is compatible charles
finds the opportunity and hits joe with
a base taking his gun away he spots the
optic impact knowing that the controller
is the man behind us turns out that
charles was the controller's boss and he
reveals the reason he kicked him away
from the project saying that was too
dangerous after that charles is shot to
death by a drone joe is ordered to cut
the man's thumb and escapes from there
he continues his mission this time the
controller commands him to head over to
redlock's head office upon arriving he
is told to wear a mask while a drone
deploys gas bombs which immediately
kills all redlocks employees the
controller explains that their lives
mean nothing in comparison to the bigger
picture which is to save the world joe
then arrives the main facility where he
uses his boss's thumb to open a door
that leads him to a huge generator joe
is forced to get into the huge device if
he wants his daughter to live the
generator starts working creating a very
blight light that eventually changes the
dna sequence inside joe's body not long
after the generator explodes and the
controller reports to his higher power
that the mission is successful zoe sees
the news on the tv and regressed her
actions towards her father earlier joe
who is covered in aluminium foil awakens
in his house and discovers that he has
now vast super powers every time he is
angry he can cast a purple colored
destructive beam from his body which
amazes the controller with his power joe
is now able to start a motorcycle
without a key to unlock his greatest
potential the controller commands joe to
head over to nico's location he arrives
at a brothel and vines nico who
distracts him with the camera's
flashlight and knocks him down realizing
that joe is red's father nico then
purposely shows a video rare being
seduced by him joe is enraged and
suddenly emits a very bright light
destroying the whole place however the
controller is not satisfied as joe still
hasn't developed a required stress level
nico's friend attempts to kill him but
the superhuman is immune to bullets the
pym tries to hit joe with his car but he
casts a gamma ray beam that kills nico
instantly a few moments later the police
arrest him and jose brought for
questioning because the police think joe
is a terrorist the controller orders him
to tell the detective that he has
planted bombs or four-river shipyard
which makes them panic and they
immediately go to the shipyard the
controller then tells joe that he must
arrive there before the police or they
will be killed by the explosion he then
escapes from the police station heads
over to the shipyard with a stolen car
however he is distracted by other police
officers therefore with his power he
then transforms into a light blast and
travels at the speed of light on the
other side the controller's men come to
zoe's house and kidnap her and her
boyfriend while the police arrive at the
shipyard and start searching for bombs
luckily joe arrives on time and manages
to take the container with the bombs to
the sky before it explodes however the
debris hits a plane's machine causing it
to fall using his power joe manages to
prevent the plane from hitting the
ground and brings it to a safer place
joe goes to zoe's house only to find out
that she has been kidnapped and the
controller threatens to kill her he's
able to track her location just by
touching the laptop's screen and
immediately rushes there to save his
daughter upon arrival he casts an
electromagnetic shield to protect his
otter the controller's men try to shoot
him but they are just wasting their
bullets as it gives no effect at all to
the superhuman he easily eliminates them
shocked that her old man is still alive
zoe finally apologizes to him for what
she had done however it turns out that
the mysterious guy that contacted the
controller earlier was michael meanwhile
the gamma ray beam is getting closer and
closer to earth realizing that michael
immediately grabs a pistol and shoots
zoe to death in front of her dad joe is
furious and kills him however he
realizes that he is unable to save his
daughter he apologizes for leaving her
alone after his wife's death to make
things worse the controller's men find
reya and kill her while the controller
broadcasts her life to joe the death of
his daughters makes joe reach the peak
level of his anger he starts emitting a
huge amount of purple light spreading
across the whole earth the light even
reaches outer space creating an
electromagnetic barrier that fully
covers and protects the earth trapped
the controller states his final words
that he has successfully created a god
fed up with his [ __ ] joe kills him
to shut him up forever however michael
and the controller's plan to save the
world is a big success as joe's
superpower manages to absorb all the
incoming gamma ray beams preventing it
from destroying the earth on the other
side jill's promised his dead wife is
finally fulfilled as he revives both of
his daughters with his power and
regroups them at the end of the movie
reya and zoe meet at the seashore and
seems like joe has fully transformed
into a superhuman form forever subscribe
to watch more videos like this turn on
notifications and leave a like to help
the channel out thank you for watching